>> AS RETURNING
OFFICER IN THE ELECTION, I CAN
CONFIRM THAT WE HAVE RECEIVED
ONE [INAUDIBLE]
[APPLAUSE] >> RISHI SUNAK IS
THERE FOR ELECTED AS LEADER OF
THE CONSERVATIVE PARTY.
>> THERE WE HAVE THE
CONFIRMATION, AS I UNDERSTAND
IT, THE WAY WE CAN INTERPRET
THAT LANGUAGE, TALK ME NOW IS
ROBERT HAYWARD, HE'S A MEMBER
OF THE CONSERVATIVE PARTY,
THERE IS ONLY ONE NOMINATION IN
THE END, WHAT SUGGEST THAT
PENNY MORDAUNT DIDN'T GET 100
MPS BACKING HER.
>> I THINK THAT'S TRUE, BUT SHE
MADE THE JUDGMENT THAT EVEN IF
SHE GOT OVER THE, MARGIN
RITCHIE WAS GETTING SO MANY
EXTRA NOMINATIONS, AND SHE
PROBABLY TOOK THE JUDGMENT
QUITE SENSIBLY.
THAT IT WOULD BE THE RIGHT
THING TO DO.
>> BUT BECAUSE IT IS ABOUT
UNIFYING THE PARTY GETTING
BEHIND ONE CANDIDATE AND A VERY
DIVISIVE TIME.
>> ONE OF HER MESSAGES HAS BEEN,
LET'S UNIFY THE PARTY.
IT'S PROBABLY THE BEST WAY OF
UNIFYING THE PARTY.
>> IT'S QUITE A STORY HOW
QUICKLY THIS PROCESS PLAYED
OUT.
BUT IS IT'S WHAT YOUR PARTY
WANTED?
>> ABSOLUTELY, NO QUESTION
ABOUT, IT I THINK --
BRADY, CHAIRMAN OF THE 1922 HAS
BEEN EXEMPLARY IN THIS PROCESS.
IT IS WORTHWHILE FOR THE PARTY.
>> BUT THE PARTY IS MUCH MORE
UNITED.
>> AND WHAT DOES IT FEEL FOR
RISHI SUNAK, HE'S A VERY
DIVISIVE FIGURE BECAUSE HE TOOK
ON BORIS JOHNSON, AND MANY
PEOPLE BLAME HIM FOR BRINGING
DOWN BORIS JOHNSON ULTIMATELY.
WHAT ULTIMATELY WAS THE APPEAL
THIS TIME AROUND THAT DID NOT
APPEAL A COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO?
>> I THINK HE WAS PROVED RIGHT
SYNDROME, AND SO HE WAS
SPENDING HIS TIME SAYING, THIS
ECONOMIC PLAN WILL NOT WORK FOR
THE FOLLOWING REASONS.
AND THE MARKETS CONFIRMED HIS
JUDGMENTS.
AND SO HIS JUDGMENT WAS RIGHT,
AND HE'S NOT GOING TO BE PRIME
MINISTER.
WE CAN JUST THROW IN, BUT IT IS
HIGHLY SIGNIFICANT BUT THIS IS
THE FIRST PRIME MINISTER FROM
AN ETHNIC MINORITY.
THE MESSAGE THAT SOUNDS TO A
WORLD WIDE AUDIENCE IS REALLY
HIGHLY SIGNIFICANT.
>> HE'S VERY MUCH SEEN AS A
FIGURE OF THE ESTABLISHMENT,
ISN'T HE?
HE WOULD VERY PRESTIGIOUS
PRIVATE SCHOOL, HE WENT TO
OXFORD IN STANFORD, HE WORKED
AT GOLDMAN STOP AND HE'S AS
SEEN AS OUT OF TOUCH BECAUSE
HE'S SO WEALTHY.
>> AND IT'S AN INDICATION OF
WHAT WE REGARD AS THE AMERICAN
DREAM.
HE IS ACTUALLY LEANING THE
BRITISH STREAM.
HIS PARENTS CAME HERE FROM EAST
AFRICA, IN THE WHOLE FAMILY,
PARTICULARLY RISHI HAS MADE A
COMPLETE SUCCESS.
AND CAN I SPEAK PERSONALLY,
BECAUSE OF A VERY CLOSE FRIEND,
WHO IS IN THE ABSOLUTELY
OVERJOYED AT THIS MOMENT AT HIS
COMMUNITY IN THE NONWHITE
COMMUNITY IS REFLECTED IN
SOCIETY.
>> IT CERTAINLY IS A HISTORIC
MOMENT, NOT JUST WHO IS BEING
APPOINTED, BUT WHAT HE
REPRESENTS.
BUT ALSO, THE AMOUNT OF PRIME
MINISTERS WE HAVE HAD, THIRD IN
A YEAR.
>> TRULY HISTORIC.
IF WE LOOK AT THE TRAJECTORY,
OSHA ST. MY PRODUCER, WE HAD
DAVID CAMERON'S PRIME MINISTER,
WE HAD THERESA MAY AS PRIME
MINISTER FOR THREE, YEARS WE
HAD BORIS JOHNSON FOR TWO AND
HALF YEARS, AND THIS TRUST AS
PRIME MINISTER FOR SIX.
WEEKS RISHI SUNAK WILL BE
HOPING TO STOP THAT TRAJECTORY
IT IS TRACKS AND HAVE THE TRULY
HISTORIC MOMENT TO HAVE THE
FIRST ETHNIC MINORITY PRIME
MINISTER, FIRST PERSON OF COLOR,
FIRST --
AND THAT WORKED UP POLITICALLY
FOR THE COMMUNITY HERE IN THE
UNITED KINGDOM.
BUT IVAN'S TO AN MP HE WAS
SAYING THAT HE SEEMS TO BE THE
RIGHT MAN TO ADDRESS THIS
CRISIS.
THIS IS FUNDAMENTALLY AN
ECONOMIC CRISIS THAT THE
COUNTRY IS FACING.
HE HAS EXPERIENCE AS CHIEF
SECRETARY TO THE TREASURY, AND
THE CHANCELLOR WITH A VERY
TURBULENT AND DIFFICULT PERIOD
IN THE COUNTRY'S HISTORY.
HE IS CONSIDERED A SAFE PAIR OF
HANDS, IT CONSIDER TO BE A VERY
INTELLIGENT PERSON.
HE ALSO HAS BEEN PREPARED TO
SUBJECT HIMSELF TO WAR MEDIA
SCRUTINY DENIS CONTENDERS IN
THE PAST FEW MONTHS.
AND THE FORMER PRIME MINISTER
BORIS JOHNSON.
AND SO I WONDER IF HE CAN
EXPECT A SLIGHT CHANGE IN THE
WAY THAT HE INTERACTS WITH
MEDIA AND COMMUNICATES.
BUT, MAX WHAT RISHI SUNAK DOES
HAVE IS SEMENYA AND WHAT NOT TO
DO AS A CONSERVATIVE PRIME
MINISTER, BECAUSE IF YOU LOOK
AT THE LAST, TO THE DOWNFALL
ABORTION, SOME OF MANY --
AS MANY WOULD ARGUE, IT'S ONE
RULE FOR THOSE WHO MAKE THEM
ANOTHER FOR THE COUNTRY AT
LARGE.
I THINK THAT WAS ULTIMATELY THE
MOST TOXIC ELEMENT OF THE
PREMIERSHIP AT THE END.
WHEN IT COMES TO LIZ TRUSS, SHE
WAS A WEAK COMMUNICATOR AND
DIDN'T GIVE THE MARCUS ENOUGH
ADVANCE NOTICE OF HER BOLD PLAN
THE DEVIATED FROM THE STATUS
QUO.
AND RISHI SUNAK WE'LL BE
STICKING TO THE MANDATE WHEN
THE CONSERVATIVE PARTY WAS
ELECTED BACK IN 2019, I'M SURE
THOSE MISTAKES HAVE BEEN MADE
BY PREDECESSORS IN THE DEMISE
AND THAT WILL BE THE FRONT OF
HIS THINKING.
HE WILL BE CONSIDERING HOW HE
CAN UNITE THE PARTY, SHE
RESHAPED THE CONSERVATIVES,
RESTORE CONFIDENCE, AND TRY TO
GIVE HIM A BIT OF A BOOST.
BUT THEY'RE LAGGING
CONSIDERABLY BEHIND THE
OPPOSITION PARTY.
>> IN TERMS OF WHAT HAPPENS NOW,
WHAT WOULD YOU EXPECT WE NEED
TO HEAR FROM RISHI SUNAK, WE
WANT TO HEAR WHAT HIS PLANS ARE,
BUT NORMALLY THE FOLLOWING DAY,
WE WILL EXPECT THE ELECTED
PRIME MINISTER TO HEAD TO THE
PALACE AND MEET THE KING, AND
THINGS HAVE BEEN MOVED AROUND
AND SPED UP, AND COULD HE MEET
THEM TODAY DO YOU THINK?
IT JUST A VISIT TO THE KING.
>> THAT IS CORRECT, AND THERE
IS AN ELEMENT OF UNCERTAINTY
HERE.
WE'RE NOT ENTIRELY SURE OF THE
PROTOCOL, BECAUSE OF COURSE
PENNY WOULDN'T HAS EXPEDITED
AND ALREADY SPED UP THE
LEADERSHIP CONTEST.
I FURRED EARLIER THAT IT IS
PERFECTLY POSSIBLE THAT YOU
WILL BE APPOINTED LEADER OF THE
CONSERVATIVE PARTY AND PRIME
MINISTER TODAY AND THE
MECHANICS OF, THAT WHETHER THAT
WILL ACTUALLY EVENTUATE, WE
WILL WAIT TO HEAR FROM THE 2022
COMMITTEE.
AND AROUND 15 MINUTES, TIME
THAT WILL BE THE FIRST MOMENT
WITHIN HIS PARTY TO FRANKLY
JUDGE HIM AND TEST HIM TO SEE
IF HE HAS THE RIGHT STUFF.
BECAUSE AGAIN, THIS WOULD BE NO
HONEYMOON PERIOD JUST LIKE WITH
LIZ TRUSS.
HE HAS QUITE A CONSIDERABLE
CHUNK OF THE PARTY WHO WERE
SUPPORTING THE FORMER PRIME
MINISTER BORIS JOHNSON.
BUT THEY DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE
THE BEST RELATIONSHIP WITH
SUNAK AND HIS CAMP.
IT IS HIS OPPORTUNITY TO SHOW
THAT HE DOES WANT TO BE THE
UNITY CANDIDATE.
AND I'VE HEARD FROM UNITY
CANDIDATES OVER THE WEEKEND
THAT HE HAS MADE AN EFFORT TO
REACH OUT TO THOSE THAT HE
DOESN'T ALWAYS AGREE WITH TO
TRY TO HAVE A FRESH START.
THAT HE DOES NOT FACTIONS AND
HE WANTS TO CHOOSE THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE BEST FOR THE ROLE, AND
NOT BECAUSE HE HAS MADE
PROMISES DURING THIS VERY SHORT
IN UNUSUAL LEADERSHIP CAMPAIGN.
>> ROBERT HAYWARD, HE WILL BE
GOING TO THE PARTY PRESUMABLY,
ADDRESSING THE PARTY.
>> I WOULD EXPECT HIM, TO HAVE
NOT HEARD THE FORMER
ANNOUNCEMENT, BUT I RESPECT HIM
TO SPEAK TO THE, PARTY NEEDS TO
GO SPEAK TO THE KING AS WELL.
BUT --
>> COULD HE MAKE THE
APPOINTMENT?
TODAY >> IT COULD, BE IT TURNS
ON THE QUESTION OF THE KING IN
TERMS OF AVAILABILITY.
I WAS INVOLVED IN JOHN MAJOR'S
CAMPAIGN, I PRESENT IN NUMBER
11 WHEN NUMBER, WHEN BUCKINGHAM
PALACE RANG INSIDE, LET'S FIX
AT THE, TEAM LET'S MAKE UP THE
FORMAL ARRANGEMENTS.
BUT IT IS A BRIEF PROCESS.
IT IS A VERY FORMAL PROCESS.
>> AND WHEN I SAID THAT THERE
WAS NOT A LOT OF FORMALITY,
THERE IS NOT A LOT OF
COMPLICATION TO.
IT THEY JUST HAVE TO AGREE TO
MEET.
>> BUT WE DON'T KNOW WITH THE
KING'S CURRENT DIARY LOOKS
LIKE.
AND SO IT'S A VERY BRIEF
PROCESS.
>> I'M PRETTY SURE IT WILL BE
VERY QUICK.
>> ON THIS QUESTION OF UNITING
THE PARTY, THERE ARE PARTS OF
BORIS JOHNSON'S CAMP WHO HATE
RISHI SUNAK.
HOW IS IT MEANT TO BUILD THOSE
BRIDGES?
HOW ARE BIG OF A DEAL IS IT FOR
PEOPLE LIKE PATEL TO COME OUT
IN SUPPORT OF HIM?
>> I THINK PEOPLE LIKE THAT
FROM THE RIGHT WING OF THE
PARTY, THAT IS SIGNIFICANT.
THAT WAS THE BRIDGE BUILDING.
THE FACT THAT THE --
CANNOT AGREE ON WHO THEY SHOULD
SUPPORT, SHOWS THAT THERE ARE
SOME PEOPLE WHO ARE STILL NOT
HAPPY.
BUT OVERWHELMINGLY, IT LOOKS AS
IF THE PARTY IS MUCH MORE
UNITED THAN IT WAS ON FRIDAY
ALTHOUGH THAT'S A PRETTY LOW
BAR.
IN SOME PROGRESS, BUT NOT ALL
THE WAY THERE YET.